[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to podcast and
the series called High School memories
my name is Dino and I'll be your host
today so without further Ado let's dive
into today's episode and embark on a
great journey together get ready to be
engaged entertained and inspired today's
topic will be about bilding in
schools bilding in schools uh pervasive
Mala is like a shadow that looms over
the lives of countless children it
manifests in in various forms from Cruel
words and actions to exclusion and
intimidation living victims emotionally
scared and
vulnerable it is the Sinister underbelly
of our educational
institutions to truly understand the
Dynamics of Bing one must spear into the
complex psych of both bullies and
victims often bullies themselves or
hering insecurities projecting their
fears into others like an emotional Hall
of Mirrors victims on the other hand
bear the heavy burden of anxiety and
self-doped living Perpetual
fear language a formidable weapon in the
hands of bullies can cut deeper than any
physical blow words can be like shs of
glass living emotional scores that last
a lifetime to combat billing we must
encourage a lexicon of empathy and
respect replacing hurtful phrases with
empowering
ones the roots of building often extend
into the very system of educational
institutions a cultor that turns a blind
eye to such a behavior is
complicit to eradicate this maners
schools must enact strict anti Belling
policies and create an atmosphere where
students feel safe for rep in incidents
without fear of
Retribution teachers the custodians of
knowledge also bear the weighty
responsibility of shaping your minds in
terms of empathy understanding and
emotional
intelligence as mentors they can
intervene uh mentor and Foster a sense
of community in the classroom making it
a place where is simply
unacceptable
in the battle against parents are
our Vital
allies they must actively engage with
their children teaching them the values
of kindness inclusivity and staining up
for those in need it is within the
familial Caron that the seeds of
compassion can be
sound for victims of building resilience
is their armor and support is their
Shield
they must be encouraged to seek help to
confide in friends family or mental
health professionals as the journey from
victim to Survivor is a path paved with
strength and
support link prevention is a critical
and multiac approach aimed at reducing
and ultimately eradicating bullying
behavior in schools combinations and
online
spaces here are some key aspects and
strategies for building
prevention the first one education and
awareness one of the fundamental steps
in profession is to educate students
parents teachers and the community about
what constitutes bilding its various
form like verbal physical social and C
Belling and its harmful effects this
awareness helps in early identification
and
intervention the second one establish
clear policies schools should have well-
defined anti building policies in place
at lining the consequences for bullying
Behavior and the procedures for
reporting and addressing incidents these
policies must be communicated to
students and
parents
the third one peer support and bystander
intervention encouraging students to
look out for one another and report
bilding is vital peer support programs
and teaching students how to be
effective by standers can make a
significant difference in preventing
incidents the last and the fourth one is
parent
involvement parents play a critical role
in bullying prevention like I said
earlier schools should engage parents in
process educating them about the signs
of building how to support their
children and how to work with the school
to address any
issues okay so in conclusion bullying in
schools is a societal scor that
necessitates or Collective
commitment we cannot and must not
tolerate the pain it inflicts upon our
children to borrow a phrase from mahma
gante we must be the change we wish to
see in the
world let's work together to create a
world where every child can flourish
without fear where schools are
sanctuaries of learning and
compassion thanks for joining us on the
imperative Journey through the dark
corridors of billing if you found this
episode and lightning share it with your
network together we can break the chains
of billing and Ur a brighter future for
the Next Generation until next time stay
tuned to high school
[Music]
memories